suelen preguntarme si los genios nacen o
se hacen
bueno en mis primeros años como
entrenador de iniciadas de matemáticas
ocurrió que a la par me pidieron que
trabajar con niños que tenían problemas
en matemáticas eran niños que iban de
sexto de primaria a primero de
secundaria
ocurrió que en ese grupo había una niña
muy buena todas las operaciones las
hacia muy rápido y como cualquier niño
bueno que termina rápido hacía caos en
el salón entonces para tenerla
controlada le ponía problemas problemas
de limpiado de matemáticas
resultó que era muy buena resolviendo
los y entonces decidí invitarla al
taller de olimpiadas de matemáticas y
ella al principio tenía mucho miedo lo
que dijo fue yo no soy buena me
conociste en un taller para niños con
dificultades en matemáticas entonces por
qué me invitas a trabajar con chicos que
son muy buenos entonces tuve que
convencerla y empezó a ir al taller
cuando ya por fin llega primero de
secundaria decide inscribir la una
limpia de matemáticas contra
preparatorias porque en ese entonces no
existían olimpiadas ni de primaria y de
secundaria
como yo ayudo en el diseño de estos
concursos sabía que ya no podía ganar
porque de los cinco problemas que iba a
resolver tres de ellos requerían un
conocimiento algebraico que ya todavía
no tenía era muy joven
pero mi idea era que igual que en un
deporte ella tenía que adquirir la
experiencia tenía que perder el miedo
para que después para mejor
bueno resulta que cuando llega el día
del concurso ella no sabía que había
problemas que no podía resolver y qué
pasó que lo resolvió de manera
completamente diferentes a como nosotros
esperábamos
y ella alicia cambió nuestra manera de
ver lo que podía hacer un chico de
secundaria y varios años después empezó
a cambiar nuestra forma de ver lo que
podía hacer un chico de primaria
bueno allí se empezó a participar en
concursos ella fue la primera persona de
primera y secundaria que logró obtener
medalla de oro al competir contra
preparatorias ella siguió participando y
terminó yendo a la olimpiada mexicana de
matemáticas al concurso nacional y ahí
pues ella logró obtener medalla de oro y
estuvo en el equipo de primer lugares
nacionales y después siguió pasando el
tiempo y quedó preseleccionada para
representar a méxico en la olimpiada
internacional de matemáticas
pero por desgracia no pudo ir solo van
seis chicos del país a representar a
méxico y ya queda en séptimo lugar pero
si lo piensan un poco fue una niña que
salió de un taller para chicos que
tenían dificultades en matemáticas y
logró ser la séptima mejor del país
a mí me preocupaba que ella
fuera a desmoralizarse por no haber ido
al internacional pero esta experiencia
cambió su vida ir a las olimpiadas
matemáticas le cambió su vida y sé que
esa frase se usa mucho muchísimo pero en
esta situación fue real porque ella de
ser una niña que creía que tenía
problemas en matemáticas
finalmente las amo tanto que decidió
estudiar matemáticas hizo su
licenciatura su maestría actualmente
tiene un doctorado trabaja en una
universidad en eeuu sigue entrenando
chicos para olimpiadas de matemáticas y
ha trabajado en varios proyectos para
llevar matemáticas a minorías trata de a
través de la belleza de las matemáticas
sacar a gente de situaciones muy
difíciles algo que es muy importante es
que allí se encontró una comunidad
cuando tú encuentras un chico
que tiene dificultades para expresar sus
ideas
cuando lo llevas a un espacio en donde
los demás lo van a escuchar en donde
puede hacer que sus ideas crezcan en
donde tiene compañeros que tienen más
experiencia y se le van a transmitir
este talento latente que está ahí
empieza a florecer
bueno algo que es muy importante es que
esta experiencia también cambio mi vida
ahí me di cuenta de que era muy
importante escuchar los chicos que ellos
tienen ideas muy buenas y a veces
nosotros no las entendemos me di cuenta
que en muchas ocasiones el talento surge
de donde menos lo esperas nadie
esperaría encontrar alguien talentoso en
matemáticas en un grupo de chicos con
dificultades
otra cosa que fue muy importante y de la
que me di cuenta es que en muchas
ocasiones estos chicos ni siquiera se
dan cuenta que tienen ese talento
la mayoría de la gente no se da cuenta
de cuándo es realmente bueno en algo y
necesitan llegar a una comunidad en
donde sus ideas sean apreciadas para que
ellos puedan crecer
y algo que fue muy importante ahí me di
cuenta que una parte del genio nace pero
otra la más importante se hace y se hace
con mucho trabajo y eso no te lo dicen
en la escuela no suelen decir tú vas a
triunfar vas a hacer cosas grandes pero
nunca te dicen cuánto vas a tener que
trabajar
si un chico no llega a un lugar adecuado
ese genio se puede morir
al trabajar con los dos extremos con los
chicos muy talentosos y los chicos que
tienen dificultades me di cuenta de que
muchas veces la diferencia entre unos y
otros es que el talentoso es una persona
a la que en algún momento le dijeron qué
bonita idea cuéntame más mientras que el
que siente que no es bueno para algo
normalmente le dijeron no así no y
piensan un poco estoy seguro que a la
mayoría de usted les pasó alguna vez van
orgullosos con un maestro y le presentan
una solución
y el maestro les dice está mal pero
porque si es la respuesta correcta pues
porque no es así como te lo enseñan
miles o tres veces una persona y en el
mejor de los casos va a ocultar sus
ideas en el peor de los casos va a decir
yo no soy buena en esto y lo va a
abandonar el genio se puede matar muy
fácilmente algo que es muy importante es
que todos los niños deberían vivir la
oportunidad de estar en una comunidad
adecuada y por desgracia la escuela
normalmente no es esa comunidad al
trabajar con chicos talentosos he
encontrado varios tipos está el engreído
que los hay claro que sí está ahí que
desde pequeño le dijeron tú eres un
genio eres bueno todo te sale bien y
ellos creen que no hay que esforzarse
para lograr las cosas porque su
experiencia así ha sido se han
enfrentado a cosas sencillas las han
sacado fácilmente y no aprenden a
esforzarse y en muchas ocasiones va a
llegar un momento en que ellos van a
topar con pared
no van a poder resolver algo y tienen
baja tolerancia a la frustración no es
bueno decirle a un niño eres un genio
claro que hay que reconocerle sus logros
pero hay que enseñarle que es importante
el trabajo muy importante hay otro tipo
de chicos talentosos que son los
mesurados con ellos es muy fácil
trabajar porque ellos ya encontraron una
pasión desde muy pequeños ya se dieron
cuenta de que hay algo que pueden amar
algo que les gusta y quieren conocer más
esos pues incluso sin un maestro con un
pequeño grupo de amigos pueden lograr
muchas cosas pero hay algunos grupos y
esos son los que más cuidado requieren
los tímidos
los que empezaron a mostrar que eran muy
buenos en algo y se les dijo no y se
empieza y empiezan a ocultar sus ideas
se suele decir mucho que los artistas
los científicos son gente muy retraída
en muchas ocasiones es porque sus ideas
no eran entendidas por los demás y
entonces lo que ocurrió fue que si no me
entienden para que las digo en muchos
casos no solo no los entienden algunos
casos los excluyen y este otro grupo el
que ni siquiera sabe que tiene un
talento latente ahí
tiene un gran potencial y eso es
importante porque es un potencial y
mientras no se trabaje no va a pasar de
eso y bueno hay un grupo más pero esos
no suelen llegar a los concursos son los
que dicen yo nunca he sido bueno para
nada nunca encontré un talento no
llegaron al lugar adecuado
a cualquiera de estas personas le ayuda
mucho llegar a una comunidad al engreído
porque se va a dar cuenta de que hay
mucho qué puede aprender puede crecer
muchísimo
se va a dar cuenta que hay gente que
tiene niveles más altos y que hay que
trabajar para alcanzarlos hay que
encontrar lo que le gusta el mesurado
pues esos desde siempre están buscando
una comunidad el tímido una vez que lo
pones en la comunidad adecuada deja de
serlo y sus ideas se empiezan a florecer
él empieza a brillar
y el que no sabía que tenía un talento
si no llega una comunidad adecuada ese
genio se va a morir todos los niños
deberían vivir una experiencia así
constantemente cuando nos ven trabajar
con niños muy pequeños de primaria por
ejemplo matemáticas nos dicen les está
robando la infancia
la crema
ellos son más juguetones ellos siguen
explorando el mundo ellos disfrutan lo
que hacen simplemente encontraron algo
apasionante desde muy jóvenes y no lo
van a perder toda su vida al contrario
les estamos prolongando la infancia se
necesitan más comunidades de este tipo
no solo de matemáticas de todas las
ciencias de deportes de arte es
importante que la gente pueda descubrir
algo que le apasione porque hay mucho
más talento del que solemos creer lo que
no hay son suficientes espacios si esos
espacios empiezan a generar vamos a
tener gente que quieren mostrarle esa
pasión a los demás que buscan despertar
esa pasión en el resto vamos a tener a
gente que va a ser una motivación para
los demás va a ser un ejemplo van a
querer seguirlo si él pudo hacerlo yo
puedo hacer como él
van a encontrar chicos que descubren
algo nuevo algo porque apasionarse que
empiezan a buscar nuevas áreas en donde
aplicar su conocimiento van a crear
cosas nuevas van a ayudar al país a
salir adelante esto ya encontraste tu
comunidad
tu pequeño tu hijo tu nieto ya encontró
su comunidad
[Aplausos]